hey guys up welcome back to cooking with
Justine today we're going to make
something that one of you guys tweeted
me it's this vine of somebody making
this really cool like pizza roll-up
thing and use these Prasant
things clearly I know exactly what I'm
doing so I got pizza crust pizza sauce
pizza cheese whatever I needed two of
these I've only got one this might be a
very tiny pizza one pizza crust I need
to the only thing that I have that's
similar to that is this croissant
crescent roll let's see what happens
hmm I don't think I have a pizza peel
and pop he'll press spoon at seam until
pops open aha spin pop done magic oh
gosh let's see what are the directions I
lost my directions now thin crosses
shouts
I just like peel this that all this just
freakin rolls out like this this is
magic oh gosh oh no oh no no no who said
this was a good idea so to achieve what
I want to do I don't think I'm gonna be
able to do it
I think everyone did okay this is this
is Oregon oh I wanted to fold it in half
now it's all sticky
let's scrunch this together shout out a
row from nerdy nummies who gave you this
amazing rolling pin because if she
didn't guess what I wouldn't have one
yep things are going great no this is
not working what the hell are you doing
why are you scrunching up like that guys
remember what I said I was begging you
pizza I hope you weren't hungry stops
crunching back up pizza stretching oh
like this I feel defeated
hmm that's good yeah one looks great
cool let's put a little sauce on our
pizza this is not anything that I had in
mind at all businesses to be a thin
crust pizza Oh we'll put our cheese on
our pizza that's good on the vine that I
saw they have this nice little cover on
it and then they cut it in the neighb
wrapped it and yeah push spoon it seemed
because I'm using pizza dough and I'm
putting croissant rolls over top of it
this is a new thing no just put that
these are two completely different types
of dough I'm going to call this
know what to call it a beautiful mistake
he'll cover that up right there let's
put this in the oven okay let's check
out the pizza the pizza
I think it's cooked we'll just put a
little cheese on top cool hmm yeah so it
comes up um I made a calzone this is not
anything at all what I wanted to walk
have to make I want you to see what I
actually meant to make I don't
understand how this keeps happening I'm
not sure either I'm like that bad though
yeah but I want to show you what this
was supposed to us a lot of braids the
topless croissant dough because I
thought that I bought two things a pizza
dough and I didn't the bottom is
supposed to be a thin crust pizza oh why
not
it's not cooked hey can you guys come
here and see what this is supposed to
look like yeah well how did you screwed
up isn't it look good
you're not even in the same realm it's
like you literally took dough put cheese
and marinara sauce on it put dough on
top that's exactly what I did do because
I messed up well then why did you
toasted like that well I didn't you cut
it like that because I couldn't because
all right guys thanks for watching I
hope you learned something today these
drones actually out right now for
consumers or this is so this is out here
this is the Q Python in the third
quarter the typhoon Hobi which has Intel
built inside